one week after the 2016 general election
Hillary Clinton's lead in the popular
vote has surpassed the 1 million vote
mark uh and this is so important in so
many different ways according to the
cook Political Report hillary clinton
now leads donald trump by more than 1
million votes in the popular vote
according to the new york times popular
vote tally uh I did I say electoral vote
I mean popular vote according to the New
York Times popular vote tally Hillary
Clinton leads Donald Trump by more than
a million votes there's an estimate from
the nation which suggests that the
electoral vote lead in spite of going in
Trump's uh direction might not consider
that the popular vote lead for Hillary
Clinton could end up being at over two
million votes maybe that is one estimate
from the nation in previous presidential
elections we saw the winning candidates
win majorities of the popular vote more
than fifty percent not only did Donald
Trump not win a majority of the popular
vote he didn't even win a plurality of
the popular vote and this is one of the
biggest non mandate wins if there is
such a term in a very long time
corporate media won't talk about it they
have no interest whatsoever Donald Trump
lost the popular vote by more than a
million votes but it is full steam ahead
on corporate media and there is a
meaning here that's really important Pat
it's not that oh well Hillary Clinton
should be given the election know we
have an electoral vote system in the
country we've talked about that that's
the system we have the meeting here is
that a million more people voted for
Hillary Clinton than the guy who is
barreling towards inauguration on
january twentieth not only that Trump
received under fifty percent of the vote
in a majority of individual state
contests this is the biggest non mandate
we have had in a very long time and we
need to remember that when people say
hey Trump won and now he gets to do
whatever he wants most people voted for
somebody else yet you can't change the
rules of the game after the game has
been played we all recognize that that's
not what we're advocating for right
we're talking about getting rid of the
Electoral College in the future and you
say he doesn't really have a mandate and
you
that he has all three branches of
government on his side so who's going to
enforce that really George Bush tin when
the popular vote either yet he was just
given his war in Iraq so we'll have to
see how this goes in the future when
people tell you to get over it tell them
yeah you know I agree with Trump on this
who made it clear in 2012 that the
Electoral College is a disaster for
democracy and Pat is right you've got a
gerrymandered House of Representatives
which allows Republicans to win well
more than fifty percent of the seats
with well under fifty percent of the
vote and then you've got this situation
in the White House where you also have
the biggest non mandate for a president
in a very long time but who is going to
stop Trump it's going to take Democrats
using whatever tools are available to
them whether it's the house or the
Senate or whatever whatever Ben you were
talking about to stop Trump from doing
whatever it is that he wants it's an
uphill battle for the next four years at
minimum for the next two but probably
probably four is a major uphill battle
but this is actually an incredibly poor
showing this is one of the least uh
least supported upcoming presidents that
we will have ever had in the history of
the United States and the trumpets need
to remember that when they see the
opposition to trump that I hope
Democrats have a spine and actually put
into practice over the next two and four
years let's take a break we'll be back
after this gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
tdps the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s